there are two ways to close a mouth one
involves actually what we call a needle
injector so this is normally going into
bone
[Music]
so the wire holds it in place hello i'm
victor m sweeney licensed funeral
director and mortician and this is part
two of mortician support
[Music]
all right first up here's a question
from lovely nicole how do morticians get
into their profession like what inspired
them or what not to want to pursue that
career that is such a fine question um
it differs from mortician to mortician
decades ago it used to be more common
that a funeral home was a family
business so it might be that your dad
was a mortician and your grandpa before
him and you just follow in their
footsteps to carry on that family
business and keep up the family name
today most morticians are what we might
call first generation funeral directors
so they're going into it cold they're
learning the trade and then going off on
their own to either work for somebody or
own their own funeral home for myself i
always grew up kind of surrounded by
death if you will i found my best friend
uh dead in his bed when he was when i
was four i had a sister that was born
before me that passed away and we'd
always visit her grave and then for
about 10 years when i was a kid we lost
a close family member an aunt an uncle a
grandparent every year for about a
decade so i was around funerals a whole
lot it made me understand that this is
something important and worth doing
here's a question from anthony pyle can
you be buried according to your heritage
or beliefs in colorado for instance
there is one county that actually allows
burial outside on a pyre so you could
build a
a burial pyre out of wood and light up
grandpa if you were in that county and
you had proper write-off from the
government next up we have from
a total random why do dead bodies get
stiff the proper term for the stiffening
of bodies after death is called rigor
mortis so this would be when the muscles
of the body tense up until the tissues
themself start to break down a little
bit so if a body is in rigor and we
don't want it to be the best thing that
we can do is what's called breaking
rigor typically you're gonna see rigor
mortis in the joints is where it's
primarily going to be a problem so to
break rigor all you actually have to do
is manipulate those joints forcefully
and i'm talking bending those fingers
way way back and after you do that a
number of times they'll loosen up so
then you can have the hands positioned
properly our next question is from
alicia wood will morticians give you a
shower asking for a friend it's a fine
question because really we do bathe
every deceased that comes through so
we'll wash their bodies we'll shampoo
their hair but for your question giving
a shower i cannot imagine trying to prop
somebody up
trying to make that happen having them
laying on a table and doing it while
they're laying down and i don't have to
hold them up with one arm is that
definitely ideal here's a question from
sovereign insane if somebody wished to
be turned into a life-size doll after
death would it be legal
absolutely not here's a question from vv
capitalism
how do morticians fix a body that was
shot between the eyes like they just
fill it in with silly putty one of the
things that we do and we work very hard
on is what we call restoration when
someone shot between the eyes provided
the rest of their head is there and we
just have a bullet hole first we'd
probably want to pack it with cotton or
some other firmer material and then on
the topmost layer we're going to cover
it with what's called a wax this wax is
called the surface restorer so i'll show
you how it works
so we have a wax it's softer than candle
wax but when it's introduced to the heat
of the hand it tends to soften up and
then this wax we can use to wax over a
wound see how it covers it just like
that and then we can get the proper
texture with stippling and with brush
work and then color over it after that
and try to blend it in here's a question
from genealogy jill are sky burials
legal in the united states so a sky
burial is where you leave a body out on
a high place for vultures and other
animals to pick apart it is not legal
here's a question from kelly elizabeth
you
do morticians really sew your mouth shut
when you're dead hashtag the right the
answer to that is
yes and also no you might be thinking
that we're talking about sewing the lips
we generally don't sew the lips closed
you can imagine how much time and how
much fine detail it would take to do
that there are two ways to close a mouth
one involves actually using suture to
bring the jaw bone
up with
a needle and some thread this is a large
s curve needle you would go up
out of the nose across the septum
back down and then you're actually going
to go through the frenulum the frenulum
of your lip here there's usually a
little piece of skin you'll go through
that on the inside of your mouth once
you do that you can just pull the two
ends together and it tightens the jaw
right up the other method of closing a
mouth is with what we call a needle
injector we have a mouth here and we're
going to take
this needle injector and it's a piston
you see it clicks so this piston is
going to drive our sharp brad into the
wood here just as a demonstration so
this is normally going into bone
so there's our bottom one
there's our top one and then you simply
twist them together
so the wire holds it in place once the
jaw itself is closed the lips and the
rest of the mouth take their form very
naturally here's a question from haley
hey how do morticians do people they
knows bodies i could never i actually do
that pretty frequently and honestly it's
kind of nice because you know the person
you know how they do their hair you know
how they do their makeup you know how
they like to get dressed and here's a
question from ambryn when viewing my
grandmother for her funeral i noticed
her nose looked odd upon closer
inspection it appeared to have been
squashed and carefully restructured is
this a common occurrence amber that is a
good question and i'm sorry that was
your experience i wouldn't say it's
common but it depends on the manner of
death so let's say someone passed away
where they had a very quick heart attack
and fell onto their face it's possible
their nose might have been broken or
maybe they laid on their nose for a
number of hours and it maintained that
squashed look then it would be just as
simple as straightening it out maybe
putting a little cotton in the nostrils
to hold their shape and then embalming
the body so those tissues hold their
shape here's a question from tiffany
payne do breast implants get taken out
five question marks
short answer
no
our next question is from ot how do
morticians decide what to do with the
dead person's arms so that's kind of an
interesting question um traditionally
the hands are placed over the umbilicus
so over the navel and almost always the
hands are going to be positioned left
over right the reason being is that more
often than not by the time you pass away
you will have been married so we want
the hand with the wedding ring to be on
top so people can see it but maybe the
variation on that is if we have someone
who's very large and in the casket
sometimes their hands don't quite reach
up or maybe they
would meet but it's so high up in the
casket we wouldn't be able to close the
lid securely so if that's the case we
usually just put the hands at the side
typically resting just on top of the
hips here's a question from aaron
execution i wanted to go into the field
of work back in the day but i was afraid
of how it would affect me what's one
situation that's affected you the most
good and bad could that line of work
cause ptsd well the truth of it is um it
can be a very emotionally taxing job you
do see a lot of things that you just
don't want to see graphic injury
increasingly decaying bodies burying
children all those things are really
really really hard but there are a lot
of good things too for instance
when you come across a situation like
that you're in a position to actually
help a family in a way that really
nobody else can as for it causing ptsd
maybe i think it depends on the person
but i think if you put the idea that
you're there to help first kind of
before your own
emotional investment in it that's
probably the ticket to keeping you free
of those kind of debilitating anxieties
next up we have a question from horror
of the orient why do dead bodies have to
be prepared and just toss me into
the ocean why is it so complicated just
drop me in and let the orcas eat me that
could possibly be an option if we're
talking about burial at sea the reason
we prepare bodies is to provide time for
families to gather more often than not
states are going to have a limit between
the time a person passes away and when
they have to be either buried or
cremated with embalming it actually
negates the necessity to bury a person
right away so let's say we're having a
funeral and we have families coming from
both sides of the country hard to do
that in 72 hours let's say if we embalm
a body then we don't have to worry so
much about the timing and we can delay
it a little bit if we need to i don't
have a great deal of experience with
burial at sea
being in the most landlocked state in
the country
but but there are protocols for um
shrouding and wrapping and then
disposing of a body a certain number of
miles out on the coast um so that way
when it goes overboard it doesn't wash
up on shore and the orcas get to eat you
just as you wished here's the next
question from dollar sign do morticians
really remove all the inside organs and
put them at the foot of the dead person
in the casket or is that a lie
thankfully that is an outright lie
typically with an embalming we don't
have to remove the organs at all they
can just stay right in the body even if
we have an autopsy in which the organs
have been removed for study they're
typically placed back in the body cavity
so putting them in a bag at the end not
going to happen and at any rate it's a
huge liability what if it broke open or
what if it was just sloshing around in
the end as you carry the casket out you
don't want that we don't want that
no our next question is from frantic
woman can morticians put facial
expressions on the dead that is a great
question yes more or less so typically a
person's facial expression will almost
make itself when we close the jaw and
set the features now there are things we
can do
to help create a more pleasant
expression things like
filling in some of the cheek let's say
they've
gotten older maybe losing some of their
muscle tone we can fill in the cheek
with some cotton or possibly some fluid
that we can inject in to bulk it up a
little bit one of the things that i
always do is i put a little bit of
cotton inside the mouth under the turn
at your mouth when you smile in my
experience generally people that smile
more have nicer expressions when they're
in the casket and people that are
frowners they tend to frown in the
casket as well here's a question from
jordan are all morticians this hot uh
the short answer to that is no i usually
look like a pasty stringy just
stereotypical mortician when they put me
in front of the lights with studio magic
i look very handsome our next question
is from elian hey i have a question what
do you do if a person has died in some
kind of accident and has a severe injury
for example lost a limb do you fix the
part of the body that was injured
decapitated or do you simply put it back
asking out of curiosity really ellie it
depends on the type of injury and maybe
the magnitude of it so if someone loses
a limb let's say if the limb is
relatively intact apart from being
severed from the body we can
re-articulate it and actually just sew
up all the tissue around it making sure
it's properly embalmed i have not
thankfully had too much experience with
decapitation but the way a person
handles that you embalm the head
independently from the rest of the body
and then when it comes time to
re-articulate the head to the rest of
the spinal column you actually drive a
dowel into the spine and then set the
atlas of the head the rest of the neck
on top of that dowel so you know it's in
the proper place then it's just a matter
of carefully stitching up the two ends
of the skin together and waxing over it
here's a question from the kryptonite do
you know why do dead bodies float yes
the reason for that is a bacterial
buildup in the abdomen that creates gas
that gas will cause the body to float
here's a question from
dinah jarrett the five-year-old
questions
why do dead bodies stink asked during
breakfast no less well i have a
five-year-old at home and this is
probably a normal breakfast for me do
you ever have meat or any other
vegetable that goes off spoils or rots
that is exactly what our bodies do as
soon as our immune systems stop taking
care of us you have a lot of internal
bacteria living in your gut all those
hollow organs and those things do smell
bad if a body comes in already smelling
bad already partially decomposed
typically we'll put that body in a body
bag if they're not not already in one
and then a good way to reduce smell is
to actually use baby powder as well as
baking soda both those soak up those
nasty smells quite well as long as the
body's in a sealed pouch if we have an
embalming where somebody is is smelling
bad really the embalming itself
typically will fix some of that smell
ideally the fluid will push out the
blood and a lot of times as soon as as
that blood is gone the smell goes with
it too if someone is smelling really bad
a nice trick is just a little bit of
vicks vaporub under the nose the next
question is from jash is it possible for
a mortician to allow someone to watch
while they're working on a body that is
a great question the answer is no
unless they are actually an intern in
most states they won't allow anybody
outside of someone who has a funeral
doctor's license to enter into an
embalming room let alone watch the
preparation of a body our next question
is from rl queen how do hair and nails
still grow on the body after death that
is an interesting question the hair and
nails do not continue to grow after
death there are no
life processes that would cause the
growth of hair or nails the look of hair
growing and nails getting longer is
primarily from skin around them
retracting our next question is from
lord and savior jared gaines i heard of
a thing where you would die and you can
have your tattoos preserved and given to
your loved ones have you ever done
something like that i've never had that
request but i have looked into a company
that does do that so really what we
would have to do is just remove that
outer layer of skin the company would
probably send us a biohazard shipping
container so we could mail that top
layer of skin with the tattoo off for
preservation and then probably framing
before they would send it back to the
family here's a question from job for a
cody so i do have a serious question
what are happening to the bodies of the
deceased with coronavirus are they
cremated are morticians wearing hazmat
suits or something that is such a good
and relevant question so when someone
dies from coronavirus they do not have
to be cremated right away we can embalm
their body it was kind of scary right
away because i remember very distinctly
um handling bodies of people that had
died of the coronavirus before we knew
how it was spread we always wore the
maximum number of personal protective
equipment that we could so not quite a
hazmat suit but the next thing closest
to it coronavirus is spread by droplet
infection right by respiration from the
body whenever you manipulate a body
let's say from the place of death there
is going to be some expulsion out of the
out of the lungs right as coronavirus
started we would start to shroud every
body with a plastic shroud to contain in
any sort of expulsion from their mouth
whether aspiration or just simply breath
you wouldn't normally think that that
would be a problem with a dead body but
as it turns out we would always see kind
of foggy condensation on that plastic
shroud right around the face and that's
it thank you for all your great
questions again i was happy i could
inform and teach you guys a little bit
more about my life in the deaf world